[Música]
quien de chico una persona curiosa
aquí le gustaba hacer experimentos soy
chico siempre fui muy curioso siempre
buscaba la misma respuesta cómo
funcionan las cosas eso obviamente me
llevó a meterme en muchos problemas como
por ejemplo cuando literalmente desarme
todo un estéreo de mi hermano de esos
que venían con doble casetera y para
pensar acostados simplemente para saber
cómo funcionaba casi me mata
o también cuando estaba en jardín en mi
casa con mi prima y empezamos a prender
fuego una ramita de un árbol pero nos
una rendimos otra hasta que sin darnos
cuenta se prendió todo el árbol foro
salimos corriendo nos metimos abajo en
la cama y no salió hasta dueños los
bomberos
todo eso simplemente para saber cómo se
prendía la ramita fuego
durante mi infancia como estaba más o
menos en cuarto o quinto grado me topé
con una de las mayores dificultades de
mi vida que me acompañan día a día y que
hacen que cada proceso de mi vida sea un
desafío la dislexia
muchos acá deben saber o debe haber
escuchado hablar alguna vez en su vida
de que es la dislexia bueno para los que
no la dislexia es un trastorno del
aprendizaje de la lectoescritura de
carácter persistente y específico
no entendieron nada no bueno vamos a
meternos en mi cabeza
y pudieron de lo fácilmente cuestan o
bueno así funciona la mente un disléxico
para nosotros es esa dificultad que
tenemos para leer y escribir porque nos
confundimos unas letras o palabras con
otras cuando me diagnosticaron dislexia
no estaba muy instaurado ni el
diagnóstico y el tratamiento entonces
pasé por muchísimos o por lo menos lo
cambien parecían que eran muchísimas
test entrevistas consultas con médicos
psicopedagogas hasta que empezaron a
probar con la medicación
la famosa ritalina
ahora yo siempre cuento esta anécdota
porque para mí me marcó para el resto de
la vida una de las tantas veces que
salía de la consulta del médico bajo los
efectos de la medicación y batán boleado
que al cruzar la calle sin darme cuenta
casi de pisón autos aire y hama basta
hay que usar más nada con esto como la
bola gota que rebalsó el vaso no me
sentía yo mismo y a partir de ahí empecé
como a mi forma encontrando los caminos
a sortear las dificultades que tenían la
vida
una característica tenemos todos los
seres humanos es la capacidad de
adaptarnos a situaciones adversas
cuando uno encuentra un obstáculo en la
vida siempre que la manera de sortear
los y si no puede hacerlo desarrolla
habilidades para suplir las que les trae
dificultad
imaginemos nos que vamos por un camino
con el auto y en el medio de la ruta una
piedra alguien se quedaría sin hacer
nada no todos vamos a evaluar el
obstáculo elaboraremos algunas hipótesis
y pondremos en marcha la hipótesis que
más adecuada nos pareció seguramente
cinco personas distintas el valor lo
haremos de cinco maneras diferentes
algunos lo harán más eficientemente y
más rápidamente por ejemplo costeando en
la piedra inclusive con el riesgo para
quedarnos encajados en el barro otros lo
harán más lentamente pero con mayor
cuidado
por ejemplo corriendo la piel a un
costado y otros imposible lo harán aún
más lentamente pero sin correr ningún
tipo de riesgo al hacerlo por ejemplo
llamando alguien que los ayude
bueno eso va a depender de la
característica de cada persona
las personas con diré que hacemos algo
parecido buscamos caminos alternativos
para sortear la dificultad que tenemos
en la lectura y la escritura
a mí sí me costó mucho tomar notas en
clases yo entendía cómo hacía la gente
para escuchar la clase escribir y aún
más hacerlo a la velocidad que siente
que hablan los profesores intenté de
todas las maneras posibles al principio
tomaba notas de los conceptos
importantes después empecé a tomar notas
solamente de algunas palabras claves que
quería quería acordar y siempre
terminaba perdiendo me de prestar la
atención al profesor entonces empecé a
escuchar atentamente la clase sin tomas
notas y después de pedir a las notas a
un amigo mío y así me di cuenta que yo
en mi cabeza yo haciendo como unas notas
mentales
de los conceptos más importantes de la
charla y cuando iba a las notas que me
hayan prestado me da cuenta que me
acuerda de todo lo que hay al ser
profesor y así estudiaba así obviamente
con mucho mucho esfuerzo terminé el
colegio la carrera de medicina la
residencia de pediatría y sigo a un día
a día superando cada uno mis obstáculos
por otro lado juan y matías dos
pacientes niños con trastorno espectro
autista que es otro trastorno del
neurodesarrollo necesitar o necesitan
ayuda y terapéuticas distintas y
amoldadas a cada uno no sólo porque
tienen dificultades distintas sino que
tienen personalidades distintas y
responden de distinta manera a las
terapéuticas de cada uno
juan por ejemplo es un chico que
necesita mucho más apoyo las terapeutas
de que le vayan dando paso a paso y que
le vas enseñándole cada paso del camino
del desarrollo
matías por otro lado es un paciente
mucho más independiente cambia que fue
creciendo fue incorporando y aceptando
sus dificultades y de esa manera fue con
muchísimo esfuerzo logrando superar
muchísimo más obstáculos que lo planteo
para terapeutas que cuestan mucho las
terapias y lo cansan mucho todos
necesitamos que nos enseñen el camino
que nos muestren las herramientas y nos
muestran el camino pero cada uno
necesita de manera distinta y de forma
particular individual cuando estaba en
la universidad me topé con esas palabras
que te marcan para el resto de la vida
que le han sentido cómo funcionan las
cosas esas palabras con las que decís
así funcionaba y eso es la
neuroplasticidad y ustedes me dirán qué
es eso un cerebro haciendo ejercicio
bueno en cierta forma así
algunos de haber escuchado hablar o
saber de las neuronas esas células de
nuestro cerebro que conectan todo que
hace que podamos pensar hablar correr
que conectan cada proceso de nuestro
proyecto cuerpo y nos dijeron que no se
pueden reproducir una que se morían ya
no se pueden recuperar bueno qué pasa si
les digo que esto no es del todo cierto
que existe una capacidad que tienen
estas células degeneran nuevas
conexiones entre sí y esta es la
neuroplasticidad
a mí el concepto de neuroplasticidad me
llevo a entender que cada persona puede
por caminos distintos llegar a resolver
trastorno del aprendizaje de manera
distinta
y eso me lleva a tener como pediatras
que cada persona se va desarrollando de
manera única e individual a cada persona
obviamente siguiendo un patrón y con el
conocimiento de los límites para que se
me levante las banderas rojas de alerta
y también que no todos los chicos con
trastornos del aprendizaje o trastorno
del desarrollo va a necesitar las más
terapias las más cantidad de esas
terapias están y más aún que no todos
van a llegar al mismo punto final
y eso me llevó a cambiar la forma
estructurada de evaluar la evolución de
las personas
una de las cosas más interesantes y más
lindas que tiene la neuroplasticidad es
que nos explican las cosas más simples
de la vida
como por ejemplo cuando queremos
recordar un momento importante y
logramos en la memoria o por ejemplo
cuando perdemos algo nuevo como andar en
auto es como cuando usamos la frase es
como andar en bicicleta para lo que no
hacemos hace mucho tiempo bueno esto es
porque cuando aprendimos eso creamos
nuevas conexiones y que son para siempre
entre lo único que tenemos que hacer
para recordar ese evento o eso que
aprendimos es simplemente activar ese
circuito neuronal a mí el concepto de
neuroplasticidad me llevo a entender que
cada proceso es único individual a cada
persona tanto para para aprender algo
nuevo como andar en bicicleta o recordar
un momento importante o inclusive para
superar obstáculos del neurodesarrollo
gràcia el concepto de neuroplasticidad
podemos entender y comprender que cada
persona es única individual
y que no hay que amoldar los
tratamientos según la patología sino
aprender a captar y adaptar cada
tratamiento a la persona yo soy padre y
no sé si alguno de ustedes alguna vez
tuvo que pasar por el proceso de
diagnóstico de un trastorno del
desarrollo de sus hijos pero es un
proceso muy angustiante cada uno de
nosotros sentimos como una derrota
personal cada trastorno y más aún los
del desarrollo en otros hijos es
sumamente importante entender que hay
que incluir a los padres en cada
diagnóstico de los hijos y más aún en
los trastornos de desarrollo es un
momento importante y vital para el éxito
del tratamiento que los padres estén
incluidos y que sirvan como motor y al
mismo tiempo del moderador el
tratamiento de los chicos
aprendamos a captar ya promover las
capacidades personas y con esas podemos
potenciar las para que puedan sortear
obstáculos del neurodesarrollo como
mensaje final creo que lo más importante
que nos vayamos acá imaginado en nuestro
cerebro como si fuese de plastilina que
seamos viendo a medida que hemos
aprendido algo nuevo
que miremos a nuestros hijos y que
observemos cada pequeño logro que
realizan y se los festejemos porque lo
hicieron creando nuevas conexiones que
son para siempre y eso es un esfuerzo
enorme aunque no lo parezca
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]